you spent a week in space what what
about you like who were you when you
launched and who were you when you
landed I launched as a curious Explorer
not connected to the planet but in space
you have this perspective shift called
the overview effect where you're going
around the entire planet every 90
minutes and we were flying over
Lynchburg my hometown looking down and
I'm thinking my parents are probably
having meatloaf and mashed potatoes and
we're flying five minutes later over
Paris and Leo I Hearts is saying yeah my
parents are probably having wine and
cheese and Yuri whose Russian looks off
to Moscow my parents are probably having
borscht in this little short span of
time we're in multiple time zones and
it's just it's mind-blowing so you come
back and if you didn't want to do things
to help the planet help people before
you come back because you feel connected
to the entire not just planet of the
universe